Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你只能报个假名，比如朱莉娅（Julia）。但用得越久，就越觉得自己像是在接受证人保护。等等，朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改点拿铁还来得及吗？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了，因为你完全可以在家自制浓缩咖啡。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. In the year 972, a young girl of perhaps 12 or 13, adorned in the heavy robes of an authentic Byzantine princess, weighed down with gold and precious stones, and accompanied by an intimidating train of flunkies, treasure chests, and changes of wardrobe, set sail from Constantinople. Some weeks later, she arrived in Rome. Her name was Theophanu, and Otto the Great, the Emperor of the West, was dazzled by her. He had wanted a princess for his son, and now he had one.
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。公元 972 年，一位年仅 12 或 13 岁的小女孩，身着拜占庭公主的正统厚重长袍，佩戴着沉重的金饰和宝石，在一群令人望而生畏的随从、宝箱和换洗衣物的簇拥下，从君士坦丁堡启航。几周后，她抵达了罗马。她的名字叫狄奥法诺（Theophanu），西方皇帝奥托大帝（Otto the Great）被她深深折服。他一直想为儿子求娶一位公主，现在他如愿以偿了。
The marriage contract inscribed on parchment painted to look like purple silk licensed the most splendid wedding in Saxon history. St. Peter's provided the venue. The Pope himself officiated. The very union of East and West seemed achieved as the squat and ginger-haired groom was joined to his willowy bride. So that was Millennium by Dan... By Tom Holland! Dominic, behave. By Tom Holland.
这份写在仿紫色丝绸羊皮纸上的婚约，促成了萨克森历史上最辉煌的婚礼。圣彼得大教堂提供了场地，教皇亲自主持。当矮壮且留着红发的准新郎与他那苗条的新娘结合时，东西方的统一似乎已经实现。以上就是丹……由汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）所著的《千年》（Millennium）！多米尼克，规矩点。由汤姆·霍兰德所著。
A wonderful book all about the world at the turn of the first millennium. And the princess in that story, Tom, princess sent by the Eastern Roman Emperor in Constantinople to marry the son of the Emperor of the West. She is our subject today. An extraordinary life story, a tantalizing figure. It's great to be doing a female protagonist on The Rest is History. I know we love a female protagonist, don't we? You've chosen this subject, and what's so wonderful about it is it allows us to explore
这是一本关于第一个千年之交世界的美妙著作。汤姆，故事里的那位公主，是由君士坦丁堡的东罗马皇帝派去嫁给西方皇帝儿子的。她就是我们今天的主角。一个非凡的人生故事，一个引人入胜的人物。能在《历史的余味》中讲述一位女性主角真是太棒了。我知道我们都喜欢女性主角，不是吗？你选择了这个主题，而它最美妙的地方在于，它让我们得以探索
a period of medieval history that usually seems a little bit murky to people in the English-speaking world, doesn't it? Yeah, I think it is a really, really fascinating period. And I think that Theophanu as a figure is fascinating for two reasons, really. The backdrop to her life, as you said, it's a period that isn't well-known relative, say, to other periods of medieval history, but it's a time when you can almost see the ancient world in the process of mutation into the world that we live in now. And it kind of reminds me, you are not as big a fan of natural history museums as I am. But often there may be a diorama of prehistoric mammals. Yeah, always.
一段在中世纪历史上通常对英语世界的人来说显得有些模糊的时期，不是吗？是的，我认为这是一个非常、非常迷人的时期。而且我认为狄奥法诺作为一个人物，确实有两个原因让人着迷。正如你所说，她生活的背景时期相对于中世纪历史的其他时期来说并不为人所知，但这是一个你几乎可以看到古代世界正在变异为我们今天所处世界的时期。这让我想起，你并不像我那么喜欢自然历史博物馆。但那里通常会有史前哺乳动物的立体模型。是的，总是有的。
And, you know, you might see a horse or an elephant or something and you can recognise them, but there'll also be all kinds of weird animals that have completely gone extinct. And it slightly has that quality. Hold on, is she a horse or is she a pterodactyl? I think she's more of a pterodactyl because of course the Byzantine empire has gone. Yeah. So she is a princess from an empire that has long since vanished. She's a Roman. Exactly. And I think that this is a period, it's 500 years on from the collapse of the Roman Empire in the West, but this is still a period that is massively, massively influenced by that great seismic geopolitical shock, the implosion and fracturing of the Roman Empire. Because if you think 500
而且，你知道，你可能会看到马或大象之类的动物，你能认出它们，但也会有各种各样已经完全灭绝的奇怪动物。它稍微有点那种特质。等等，她是马还是翼龙？我觉得她更像翼龙，因为当然，拜占庭帝国已经不复存在了。是的。所以她是一位来自早已消失的帝国的公主。她是罗马人。没错。我认为这是一个时期，距离西罗马帝国崩溃已经过去了 500 年，但这仍然是一个深受那场巨大的地震级地缘政治冲击——罗马帝国的内爆和分裂——所深刻影响的时期。因为如果你回想一下
years before this, so let's say 450, the Mediterranean is still just about a Roman lake. Yeah. It's the only period in history where a unitary power controls all the seaboard of the mediterranean but now at the end of the 10th century that is obviously no longer the case and essentially you have three heirs to the roman empire so the first of these is an empire that does not look to Rome as its exemplar and is not, as the Roman Empire had become, Christian. And that, of course, is the empire of Islam, the Caliphate.
这之前的 500 年，也就是公元 450 年左右，地中海几乎还是一个罗马湖。是的。这是历史上唯一一个单一政权控制了整个地中海沿岸的时期，但现在到了 10 世纪末，情况显然不再如此了。本质上，你有三个罗马帝国的继承者：第一个帝国并不以罗马为榜样，而且不像罗马帝国后期那样是基督教国家。当然，那就是伊斯兰帝国，哈里发国。
But it does occupy a large and much of the richest territory of the old Roman Empire, right? Egypt, the breadbasket, the Levant. So you've got a rival Caliphate in Cordoba at this point? Yeah. So we talked about that in an episode about the Caliphate of Cordoba that's ruled by the Ameads, who were the original dynasty, got overthrown by the Abbasids. And one of the Ameads fled to Spain and established his own little caliphate in Spain. And Cordoba is, with
但它确实占据了旧罗马帝国大片且最富饶的领土，对吧？埃及，粮仓，黎凡特。所以你当时在科尔多瓦还有一个敌对的哈里发国？是的。我们在关于科尔多瓦哈里发国的那一集里谈到过，它由倭马亚王朝统治，这是最初的王朝，后来被阿拔斯王朝推翻了。其中一位倭马亚人逃到了西班牙，并在那里建立了属于自己的小哈里发国。而科尔多瓦与
Constantinople, one of the two great cities in Europe at this period. But you also have an upstart caliphate, which originates in North Africa and is contesting what's Morocco with the Umayyads, rules much of Sicily. Sicily at this point is home to all kinds of Muslim corsairs, slavers. But the Fatimids, and they're called that after Fatima, who's the daughter of the prophet. So they claim descent from Ali, who was the nephew and the son-in-law of Muhammad, and Fatima. And they're Shia, not Sunni. And in this period, the very year that Theophanu is traveling from Constantinople to Rome,
君士坦丁堡一起，是当时欧洲的两大城市。但你还有一个暴发户式的哈里发国，起源于北非，正在与倭马亚王朝争夺摩洛哥，并统治着西西里岛的大部分地区。当时的西西里岛是各种穆斯林海盗和奴隶贩子的家园。但法蒂玛王朝，他们以先知的女儿法蒂玛命名。所以他们声称是阿里（穆罕默德的侄子兼女婿）和法蒂玛的后裔。他们是什叶派，而不是逊尼派。就在这一时期，也就是狄奥法诺从君士坦丁堡前往罗马的那一年，
the Fatimids are conquering Egypt and founding Cairo. And in 973, the Fatimid caliph will go to Cairo to kind of set up base there. So that is a massive, massive kind of geopolitical gorilla in the room. The Muslim world is by far the richest, the most powerful, the most predatory power in the Mediterranean at this period. But of course, you also have what we call Byzantium. They think of themselves as the Romans. They didn't call themselves Byzantines. So the big trend now is to lean into that, right? So there's a guy called Antony Caldellus, who's probably the most influential, younger historian of what we would once have called Byzantium. And his book is all the new Roman
法蒂玛王朝正在征服埃及并建立开罗。公元 973 年，法蒂玛哈里发将前往开罗并在那里建立基地。所以这是一个巨大的、巨大的地缘政治“房间里的大猩猩”。穆斯林世界是当时地中海地区最富有、最强大、最具掠夺性的力量。但当然，你还有我们所说的拜占庭。他们认为自己是罗马人。他们不称自己为拜占庭人。所以现在的一个大趋势是倾向于这一点，对吧？有一个叫安东尼·卡尔德利斯（Antony Kaldellis）的人，他可能是我们曾经称之为拜占庭的领域中最有影响力的年轻历史学家。他的书是《新罗马帝国》。
empire. This is basically the Roman empire. They call themselves Romans. They're still around. They're still there in Constantinople. They absolutely are. And they're making a comeback. So say AD 900, a lifetime before Theophanu is born, it's still really on its uppers. It's been fighting for its life really ever since the Arabs established their empire in the 7th century. And they twice besieged Constantinople and the Byzantines. We'll call them the Byzantines for the sake of argument. They hold out, but only just. And in 900, the Byzantine Empire has shrunk to maybe three quarters of what's now Turkey, of Anatolia, Greece, bits of the heel of Italy. But it's a thing of shreds and patches compared to what it had once been.
这基本上就是罗马帝国。他们自称罗马人。他们依然存在。他们依然在君士坦丁堡。他们绝对存在。而且他们正在卷土重来。所以说公元 900 年，也就是狄奥法诺出生前的一代人时间，它确实处于衰落期。自从阿拉伯人在 7 世纪建立帝国以来，它实际上一直在为生存而战。他们两次围攻君士坦丁堡，而拜占庭人——为了方便起见，我们称他们为拜占庭人——他们坚持住了，但只是勉强坚持。到了 900 年，拜占庭帝国已经萎缩到大约相当于现在土耳其（安纳托利亚）、希腊和意大利脚后跟部分的三分之二。但与它曾经的辉煌相比，它现在只是残垣断壁。
But in the 10th century, the empire is back on the attack. So this is the Macedonian dynasty and then the Macedonian Renaissance, right? New emperors. Yes, it is. Tough, battle-hardened. Warrior emperors, of whom the archetype is actually, he's a usurper. He's a man called Nikephorus Phokas, amusingly named. I would call him Nikephorus Ph Focas. Would you? I would, yeah. Well, he means victory bringer. Yeah. And he is a victory bringer. He brings victory.
但在 10 世纪，帝国又开始反击了。所以这是马其顿王朝，然后是马其顿文艺复兴，对吧？新皇帝。是的，确实如此。强硬，久经沙场。武士皇帝，其原型实际上是一个篡位者。他叫尼基弗鲁斯·福卡斯（Nikephorus Phokas），名字很有趣。我会叫他尼基弗鲁斯·福卡斯。你会吗？我会的，是的。嗯，他的名字意味着“胜利带来者”。是的，他确实是一位胜利带来者。他带来了胜利。
And he's very ascetic. He's very battle-hardened. He comes from the eastern limits of the empire, where people are forged in constant warfare against their Muslim adversaries. Very strong. The story told of him is that he could drive a pike right through the front of an adversary in full armour and the head would come out the back. So that's very impressive. And he is described by a very sneery Italian diplomat, who we might mention
而且他非常苦行。他非常久经沙场。他来自帝国的东部边境，那里的人们在与穆斯林对手的持续战争中被锻造出来。非常强大。关于他的故事是说，他能用长矛直接刺穿全副武装的对手，矛头会从背后穿出来。所以这非常令人印象深刻。而且他被一位非常尖酸刻薄的意大利外交官描述，我们可能稍后会提到
later on, who goes to pay a visit to him, as looking like a wildly bristling pig. And he has small eyes like a mole moles are quite blind aren't they and so this i think very unfair because he's clearly an unbelievably effective general yeah so he's he's known by the byzantines as the pale death of the saracens which i think is much more kind of complimentary yeah that's a great name and he has captured from the caliphate he's captured crete he's pushed the frontier back in Anatolia. So he captures Tarsus, the birthplace of St. Paul on the south coast. More than a hundred towns and fortresses.
他去拜访他时，说他看起来像一头毛发狂乱的猪。而且他有像鼹鼠一样的小眼睛——鼹鼠是瞎的，对吧？所以我认为这非常不公平，因为他显然是一位令人难以置信的高效将军。是的，所以他被拜占庭人称为“撒拉逊人的苍白死神”，我认为这更像是一种赞美。是的，那是个很棒的名字。他从哈里发国手中夺取了克里特岛，并将安纳托利亚的边界向后推进。他夺取了塔尔苏斯，即圣保罗的出生地，位于南海岸。夺取了超过一百个城镇和堡垒。
And very impressively, he's captured what is reputed to have been the sword of Muhammad himself, Zulfikar, the cleaver of vertebrae. Impressive achievements from a Byzantine general. Yeah, I'm sure that definitely was Muhammad's sword. I'm sure it was. So he comes to power in a coup in 963, and he rules for six years, continues his campaigns of conquest, but isn't tremendously popular, basically because he's a little bit too military. So he kind of turns the palace into equivalent of a military camp. He's constantly raising money for his campaigns.
而且非常令人印象深刻的是，他夺取了据说是穆罕默德本人的剑——佐勒菲卡尔（Zulfikar），即“脊椎劈开者”。对于一位拜占庭将军来说，这是令人印象深刻的成就。是的，我敢肯定那绝对是穆罕默德的剑。我敢肯定是的。所以他在 963 年的一场政变中上台，统治了六年，继续他的征服运动，但并不怎么受欢迎，基本上是因为他太军事化了。所以他把宫殿变成了军事营地的翻版。他不断地为他的战争筹集资金。
And he stages this brilliant kind of Justinianic tattoo in the hippodrome. So Justinian was the emperor who presided over the worst sports riot in history, where a kind of bust up between rival fans incinerates half of Constantinople. So there's a kind of echo of that. There's a riot, there's a stampede and things. And he's also alienated the church because as someone who is fighting Muslims, he's come to appreciate that Muslims think that if you die in battle, then you die as a martyr and you go straight to heaven. Yeah.
他在竞技场举办了一场精彩的查士丁尼式的纹身表演。查士丁尼是那位主持了历史上最严重体育骚乱的皇帝，当时敌对球迷之间的冲突烧毁了半个君士坦丁堡。所以这有一种回响。有骚乱，有踩踏事件等等。而且他还疏远了教会，因为作为一个与穆斯林作战的人，他开始意识到穆斯林认为如果你在战斗中死去，那么你就是作为烈士死去，你会直接上天堂。是的。
And he feels that this is an incentive for his enemies. Whereas Christians, if they kill someone, they have to do penance. And he feels it's a bit of a drag, a bit of a drag anchor. And so he asks if maybe doctrine on that could be revised and the patriarch says no and not only that but he doubles the penance that has to be done that's foolish from the patriarch i think but also nikephras phokas is not a terribly successful husband is he this is the key to his downfall so often the way in the eastern roman empire well i mean you know he's got the eyes of a mole and the the hair of a pig yeah it's not a good look whereas
他觉得这对他的敌人来说是一种激励。而基督徒如果杀了人，他们必须进行忏悔。他觉得这有点拖累，有点像拖累锚。所以他问是否可以修改关于这一点的教义，但牧首说不，不仅如此，他还加倍了必须进行的忏悔。我认为牧首这样做很愚蠢，但尼基弗鲁斯·福卡斯也不是一个非常成功的丈夫，不是吗？这是他垮台的关键。在东罗马帝国经常是这样。嗯，我是说，你知道，他有鼹鼠的眼睛和猪的头发。是的，这看起来不太好。然而
he has a young officer john simiskis who is unbelievably handsome and um 969 john simiskis just before christmas he's got a few lads with him they get in a boat they row across the bosphorus to where the great palace of the emperor is and there's a balcony and hanging from the balcony they find a basket and john smisky gets in the basket and again i'm convinced all this actually happened definitely he gets pulled up in the basket and um there waiting for him is the empress with whom john has been having an affair and the empress leads him into the Empress with whom John has been having an affair. And the Empress leads him into the sleeping quarters of her husband where he is wrapped up in a bear skin.
他有一位年轻的军官约翰·齐米斯基斯（John Tzimiskes），他长得帅得不可思议。969 年圣诞节前夕，约翰·齐米斯基斯带着几个小伙子，他们坐上一条船，划过博斯普鲁斯海峡，来到皇帝的大宫殿所在的地方。那里有一个阳台，从阳台上挂着一个篮子，约翰·齐米斯基斯钻进篮子里——我再次确信这一切真的发生了，绝对发生了——他被拉了上去，在那里等着他的是皇后，约翰一直与她有染。皇后把他带进了她丈夫的寝室，他正裹在熊皮里。
That's very military. Yeah. Snoring heavily. Yeah. And John kills him, chops off his head and displays it. And he becomes Emperor himself. So he's in a tricky position. He needs to consolidate his position as emperor. And so he looks westwards to the third of the great successors of the Roman empire,
那非常军事化。是的。打着响亮的呼噜。是的。然后约翰杀了他，砍下了他的头并展示出来。他自己成了皇帝。所以他处于一个棘手的境地。他需要巩固自己作为皇帝的地位。于是他向西望向罗马帝国三大继承者中的第三个，
which is the Latin West. So we've said 500 years since the implosion of Roman power in the West, and you have all these barbarian kingdoms that have kind of planted themselves on the rubble of the Roman Empire. And this is a period where you can see unitary states emerging in a form that we still have them today. So this is the period of England emerging as a United Kingdom. So Athelstan, the first king of United England, had ruled in the early part of the 10th century. Denmark is emerging. So Harold Bluetooth, who gives his name to Bluetooth technology because he joined all the various parts of Scandinavia together under a Christian kingship. So Harold Bluetooth is the first Christian king. England is Edgar. Is it Edgar at this point? I think it is.
那就是拉丁西方。所以我们说过，自罗马权力在西方内爆以来已经过去了 500 年，你拥有所有这些野蛮人王国，它们已经在罗马帝国的废墟上扎根。这是一个你可以看到单一国家以我们今天仍然拥有的形式出现的时期。所以这是英格兰作为一个联合王国出现的时期。所以埃塞尔斯坦（Athelstan），联合英格兰的第一位国王，在 10 世纪早期统治。丹麦正在崛起。所以哈拉尔·蓝牙（Harold Bluetooth），他为蓝牙技术命名，因为他在基督教王权下将斯堪的纳维亚的各个部分联合在一起。所以哈拉尔·蓝牙是第一位基督教国王。英格兰是埃德加（Edgar）。现在是埃德加吗？我想是的。
Edgar the Peaceable. Great. So-called because he kept peace by hanging anybody who gave him any trouble, not because he was a hippie. Tough on crime, tough on the causes of crime, Tom. Yes, exactly. Exactly. But elsewhere, it's more of a mess because what today would be France, the Low Countries, Germany, Italy, these are not anything resembling nation states at this point, because all of them are haunted by the attempt to revive the Roman empire, which had been led by Charlemagne, who in AD 800,
和平者埃德加。太棒了。之所以被称为和平者，是因为他通过绞死任何给他制造麻烦的人来保持和平，而不是因为他是个嬉皮士。打击犯罪，打击犯罪的根源，汤姆。是的，完全正确。完全正确。但在其他地方，情况更混乱，因为今天的法国、低地国家、德国、意大利，在这一点上都不像民族国家，因为所有这些国家都被试图复兴罗马帝国的企图所困扰，这最初是由查理曼大帝领导的，他在公元 800 年，
the great Frankish king, had been crowned in Rome by the Pope himself. But his empire had then split and fragmented, and the line of Charlemagne had gone extinct. So Charlemagne's empire had been divided in three, between what will become France, what will become the Low Countries and the divided line going down the Rhine to Switzerland. Lotharingia. Lotharingia, and then what will become Germany. And in the 10th century, the real motor of power, the real centre of gravity is in what will become Germany and specifically Saxony. The Saxons have been conquered by the Franks, but have now become Christian. And as is so often the way, it's the barbarian people who end up ruling their conquerors.
这位伟大的法兰克国王，在罗马被教皇亲自加冕。但他的帝国随后分裂并瓦解，查理曼的血统已经绝迹。所以查理曼的帝国被一分为三，分别变成了法国、低地国家，以及沿着莱茵河向下延伸到瑞士的分界线。洛泰林吉亚（Lotharingia）。洛泰林吉亚，然后是后来变成德国的地方。在 10 世纪，权力的真正引擎、真正的重心在于后来变成德国的地方，特别是萨克森。萨克森人被法兰克人征服，但现在已经变成了基督徒。而且正如经常发生的那样，最终统治征服者的是野蛮人。
And the great conqueror in this period is someone we have talked about on The Rest Is History. Otto the Great loves a kind of Peter Frankopan style shirt open to his navel, very, very hairy, great tufts of hair billowing out, mighty warrior, and leads a kind of ride of the Roerim cavalry charge against the Hungarians who were besieging Augsburg. So long ago we talked about that, Tom. I mean, that was when The Rest of history had four listeners. Yes. And he wins this great battle and essentially is in pole position to become emperor, to stand in a line of inheritance that goes back to Charlemagne, but then beyond that to Constantine and ultimately, I suppose, to Augustus.
而这一时期伟大的征服者是我们曾在《历史的余味》中谈到过的人。奥托大帝喜欢那种彼得·弗兰科潘（Peter Frankopan）风格的衬衫，敞开到肚脐，非常、非常多毛，大簇的毛发翻滚出来，强大的战士，带领着一种骑兵冲锋，对抗围攻奥格斯堡的匈牙利人。很久以前我们谈过那个，汤姆。我的意思是，那是《历史的余味》只有四个听众的时候。是的。他赢得了这场伟大的战役，本质上处于成为皇帝的有利位置，站在一条可以追溯到查理曼，甚至更远到君士坦丁，最终，我想，到奥古斯都的继承线上。
Yeah. But to do that, he needs the second great institution that looks back to the Roman period. And that, of course, is the papacy. Now, I'm reading your notes. The excellent looking line has been in a bad way. The pornocracy. Yes. What is the pornocracy?
是的。但要做到这一点，他需要第二个回顾罗马时期的伟大机构。那当然就是教皇制度。现在，我正在读你的笔记。看起来很棒的线条一直处于糟糕的状态。色情统治（Pornocracy）。是的。什么是色情统治？
Well, we actually talked about that in the episode we did on Pope Joan. It's the rule of prostitutes is the name that gets given. And it's probably the darkest period in the history of the papacy. And it kicks off with one of the great scandalous episodes in the history of the papacy. When in 896, the corpse of a Pope called Formosus is put on trial by one of his successors and is put on a stool. And it's kind of, you know, bits of eyeball hanging out from the skull. It's kind of stinking. Do you have anything to say for yourself? He's arrayed in his papal robes, found guilty. And the papal vestments are ritually torn off
嗯，我们实际上在关于琼教皇（Pope Joan）的那一集里谈到过。这是给出的名字，意为“妓女的统治”。这可能是教皇历史上最黑暗的时期。它始于教皇历史上最丑闻的事件之一。公元 896 年，一位名叫福尔摩苏斯（Formosus）的教皇的尸体被他的继任者之一送上审判台，并被放在凳子上。你知道，眼球从头骨里挂出来。它有点发臭。你有什么要为自己辩护的吗？他身着教皇长袍，被判有罪。教皇的法衣被仪式性地从
his corpse. The rings from his finger are removed and his corpse is thrown into the tiber where it gets rescued by a monk who then buries it. And in due course, his papacy is re-legitimised. So Formosa still ranks as a pope to this day. What has Formosa done? It's political shenanigans. It's nothing to do with theology. Okay. Because this is a period where the pope rules a chunk of Italy, but is centred in Rome. And there are very, very powerful, ambitious Roman noblemen
他的尸体上撕下。他手指上的戒指被取下，他的尸体被扔进台伯河，后来被一位僧侣救起并埋葬。最终，他的教皇身份被重新合法化。所以福尔摩苏斯至今仍被列为教皇。福尔摩苏斯做了什么？这是政治诡计。这与神学无关。好的。因为这是一个教皇统治意大利一部分，但以罗马为中心的时期。而且有非常、非常强大、雄心勃勃的罗马贵族
who essentially are trying to seize control of it. And this is where the pornography comes in. Right. It's nothing to do with pornography, or is it? Well, a porne in Greek is a prostitute. So has he been interfering with prostitutes, Formosus? No, Formosus has nothing to do with that. Formosus has been embroiled in political shenanigans, and these political shenanigans run throughout the succeeding decades. The reason that it is given the word pornography is because the papacy comes under the thumb of one particular Roman nobleman. He's called Theophilact, and he's the Count of Tusculum. And he has a wife, Theodora,
本质上试图夺取对它的控制权。这就是色情统治的由来。对。这与色情作品无关，是吗？嗯，希腊语中的“porne”是妓女的意思。所以福尔摩苏斯一直在和妓女纠缠不清吗？不，福尔摩苏斯与那无关。福尔摩苏斯卷入了政治诡计，这些政治诡计贯穿了随后的几十年。之所以给它“色情统治”这个词，是因为教皇制度受到了一位特定罗马贵族的控制。他叫狄奥菲拉克特（Theophilact），是图斯库卢姆伯爵。他有一个妻子，狄奥多拉（Theodora），
who, according to the traditions, and obviously they're written by disapproving monks, so slight pinch of salt to the stories. But the story is that she disapproving monks. So slight pinch of salt to the stories. But the story is that she becomes the lover of one of the popes, John X. And in due course, she and her husband then pimp out their teenage daughter, Marozia, to another pope, Sergius III. And so it carries on. And it's famously summed up by Edward Gibbon in The Decline of the Roman Empire. The bastard son, two grandsons, two great-grandsons, and one great-great-grandson of Marozia, a rare genealogy, was seated in the chair of St. Peter. So Marozia, the daughter of
根据传统，显然它们是由不赞成的僧侣写的，所以对这些故事要稍微打点折扣。但故事是说她成为了教皇约翰十世的情人。随后，她和她的丈夫把他们十几岁的女儿马罗齐亚（Marozia）推给了另一位教皇塞尔吉乌斯三世（Sergius III）。就这样一直持续下去。爱德华·吉本在《罗马帝国衰亡史》中对此进行了著名的总结：马罗齐亚的私生子、两个孙子、两个曾孙和一个玄孙，这是一种罕见的家谱，都坐在了圣彼得的宝座上。所以马罗齐亚，这两位罗马政治中强大人物的女儿，她基本上就是那个与一连串教皇纠缠不清的“porno”，即妓女。汤姆，这里有很多供托马斯·克伦威尔发挥的空间，不是吗？嗯，但也与改革派教皇有关，因为梵蒂冈和拉特兰宫里有很多人认为这令人震惊。在 965 年，你得到了一位在圣彼得宝座上就位的教皇，他决心阻止这一切并打破罗马贵族的权力。这对他来说很困难。他曾短暂入狱。
these two powerful figures in Roman politics, she basically is the porno, the prostitute who is engaged with a whole succession of popes. There's a lot for Thomas Cromwell to play with here, Tom, isn't there? Well, but also with reformist popes, because there are plenty of people in the Vatican and the Lateran Palace who think this is appalling. And in 965, you get a pope who takes his place in the chair of St. Peter, who is determined to stop this and to break the power of the Roman aristocracy. It's difficult for him. He's briefly put in prison.
他联系了我最喜欢的早期中世纪贵族之一。他是一位名叫潘多夫铁头（Pandolf Ironhead）的意大利王子。好名字。这太《权力的游戏》了，简直难以置信。是的。铁头。好名字。这太《权力的游戏》了，简直难以置信。在潘多夫铁头的帮助下，约翰十三世得以夺取对罗马的控制权，他打破了罗马贵族的权力，系统性地羞辱了城市长官，一个叫彼得的人。所以他们把他带到马可·奥勒留的雕像前，那是罗马游客可能
He reaches out to one of my favourite early medieval aristocrats of all time. He's an Italian prince called Pandolf Ironhead. Great name. Which is so Game of Thrones, it's not true. Yeah. Ironhead. Great name. Which is so Game of Thrones, it's not true. And with the help of Pandolf Ironhead, John XIII is able to seize control of Rome and he breaks the power of the Roman aristocracy, systematically humiliating the guy who is the prefect of the city, a guy called Peter. So they take him to the statue of Marcus Aurelius, the equestrian statue that visitors to Rome may
看到过的骑马雕像。它之所以幸存下来，是因为他们认为那是君士坦丁的雕像。他们用头发把他挂在骑马雕像上。所以他就在那里晃荡。然后他被放下来。他所有的衣服都被脱掉。他被放在一头驴上，你知道，背对着。他的脖子上挂着一个铃铛。
have seen. And it survives because they think that it's a statue of Marcus Aurelius, the equestrian statue that visitors to Rome may have seen. And it survives because they think that it's a statue of Constantine. And they hang him by his hair from the equestrian statue. So he's kind of dangling there. Then he gets taken down. All his clothes get taken off. He gets put on a donkey, you know, facing backwards. He has a bell hung around his neck.
然后他被驱赶着绕城一周。所以他被塑造成了一个绝对的笑柄。是的。然后他被扔进了地牢。我想在那之后很难恢复尊严。绝对不可能。但约翰十三世已经绝对证明了他就是权力玩家。这也就意味着，当奥托三世（Otto III），他在阿尔卑斯山以北建立了权力，
And he's then driven through the city all around. So he's kind of made a figure of absolute ridicule. Yeah. And then he's thrown into a dungeon. Hard to recover your dignity after that, I think. Absolutely impossible. But John XIII has absolutely demonstrated that he is, he's the power player. And this then means that when Otto III, who has established his power north of the Alps,
击败了匈牙利人，是一个了不起的小伙子。每个人都认为他了不起。当他来到意大利时，约翰十三世处于加冕他的有利位置。他们基本上结成了联盟。事实上，约翰十三世把受辱的长官彼得交给了奥托三世，奥托三世把他带到北方并关押在那里。约翰认为这太棒了。所以他称奥托为教会的解放者和恢复者，加冕他为凯撒。当然，这让君士坦丁堡的皇帝黯然失色。在这一点上，尼基弗鲁斯对此一点也不觉得好笑。奥托，他是一位萨克森贵族，现在声称自己是奥古斯都的继承人。他觉得他只有通过为儿子求娶一位公主，一位拜占庭公主，才能真正使这一主张合法化。于是他派了一位大使去和尼基弗鲁斯谈，一个叫利奥普兰德（Leoprand）的人，来自克雷莫纳。哦，克雷莫纳的利奥普兰德。很高兴他在
who's defeated the Hungarians, who's a tremendous lad. Everyone thinks he's tremendous. When he comes down into Italy, John XIII is in pole position to crown him. And they basically form an alliance. And in fact, John XIII hands over Peter, the humiliated prefect, to Otto III, who takes him north and imprisons him there. And John thinks this is great. So he hails Otto as the liberator and restorer of the church, crowns him as Caesar. And of course, this puts shade on the emperor in Constantinople. And at this point, it's Nikephoros who is not amused by this at all. Otto, he's a Saxon nobleman who is now claiming to be the heir of Augustus. he feels that he can only really legitimize that claim by getting a princess, a Byzantine princess, for his son. And so he sends an ambassador off to talk to Nikephoros, a guy called Leoprand, who comes from Cremona. Oh, Leoprand of Cremona. Great to have him on
节目中。他就是那个对尼基弗鲁斯非常粗鲁的人。原因在于教皇犯了一个绝对的低级错误，因为在他写给君士坦丁堡的信中，他称对方为“希腊人的皇帝”而不是“罗马人的皇帝”。小学生错误。这绝对是小学生错误。所以尼基弗鲁斯大发雷霆，拒绝与奥托的使团有任何往来，并说，不，你不能要公主。但当他被杀，约翰·齐米斯基斯取代了他的位置时，他急于巩固自己的政权。所以谈判可以重新开始。啊，好的。
the show. And he's the guy who is very kind of rude about Nikephoros. And the reason for that is that the Pope has made an absolute howling mistake because in the letters that he writes to Constantinople, he refers to the emperor of the Greeks rather than the emperor of the Romans. Schoolboy era. It's an absolute schoolboy era. And so Nikephoros is furious and refuses to have anything to do with Otto's embassy and says, no, you can't have a princess. But when he gets killed and John Samiski takes his place, he's anxious to buttress his regime. And so the negotiations can reopen. Ah, okay.
这就是狄奥法诺抵达罗马的背景。对。在罗马，人们认为狄奥法诺是皇帝的女儿。所以是约翰的女儿，是的。是的。这就是支配这场婚姻的假设，婚姻于 972 年 4 月 14 日在罗马举行，当时约翰十三世为他们主持了婚礼。但随后事实证明她实际上不是他的女儿，而是他的
And so this is the context that sees Theophano arrive in Rome. Right. And it is assumed in Rome that Theophano is the daughter of the emperor. So John's daughter, yeah. Yeah. And so this is the assumption that governs the marriage, which takes place on the 14th of April, 972, when John XIII marries them in Rome. But it then subsequently turns out that she's not actually his daughter, that she's his
继侄女。而且，你知道，奥托的随从里有人说这不行。她是“残次品”。我们应该把她送回去，要求退款。但奥托说不，部分原因我认为是因为这太尴尬了。但也因为，尽管狄奥法诺只是个小女孩，当时大概 14、15 岁。他真的能在她身上看到一些东西。他能看出她是一位令人印象深刻、令人印象深刻的女性。所以总结一下，汤姆，她嫁给了奥托大帝的儿子。也就是奥托。所以小奥托是一个你描述为矮壮且留着红发的人。他是罗恩·韦斯莱。是的。他们不会把她送回去的。
step-niece. And, you know, there are people in Otto's entourage who say this isn't on. She's damaged goods. We should send her back, get a refund. But Otto says no, partly, I think, because it would be too embarrassing. But also, I think, because even though Theophano is only a young girl, she's kind of 14, 15 by this point. He can really see something in her. He can see that she is an impressive, impressive woman. So just to recap, Tom, she has been married to the son of Otto the Great. Who is also called Otto. So Otto Jr. is a fellow who you describe as squat and ginger haired. He's Ron Weasley. Yeah. And they're not going to send her back.
他们不会把她送回去的。而且，她是不是个抢手货？是的。但我认为她是，正如我们将看到的，她是一位非常、非常令人印象深刻的女性。这很重要，因为这是拉丁基督教世界的一个时期。强大的女性在某种程度上是玩家，这可能会让一些人感到惊讶。好的。因为你可能认为这是一个毛发浓密的男人用剑互相残杀的时期。确实如此。
They're not going to send her back. And also, is she a bit of a catch? Yes. But I think she's, well, as we will see, she's a very, very impressive woman. And that matters because this is a period in Latin Christendom. Powerful women are players to a degree that some people might find surprising. Okay. Because you might think this is a period of, you know, hairy men savaging each other with swords. And it is.
但这是一个时期，保琳·斯塔福德（Pauline Stafford），一位关于这一时期强大女性的伟大作家，她称之为“女性的世纪”。所以我们提到了马罗齐亚，那位罗马妓女。我认为施加在她身上的辱骂显示了如果女性是权力玩家，她们会面临的一些惩罚。但也有很多强大的女性被纪念为伟大人物的例子。比如埃塞尔斯坦的姑姑埃塞尔弗莱德（Athelflad），麦西亚人的女领主，她在英格兰联合王国的编织中发挥了巨大作用。但真正最清楚地体现这一点的是奥托家族，也就是奥托的王朝。所以他的妹妹，
But it's a period that Pauline Stafford, who's a great writer on the subject of powerful women in this period, she calls it the century of women. So we've mentioned Marozia, the Roman porne. I think the abuse that is shoveled on her shows some of the penalties that women run if they are power players. But there are examples of very powerful women who are commemorated as great figures. So Athelstan's aunt Athelflad, the Lady of the Mercians, who plays a great role in the knitting together of the United Kingdom of England. But it's really the Ottonians, it's the family, the dynasty of Otto that you see this most clearly. So his sister,
她有一个绝妙的名字格伯格（Gerberger），好的，她嫁给了后来变成法国的国王，所以如果你想到，你知道，有德国王国，还有我们称之为法国王国，是的，法兰克王国，她为他生了八个孩子，但她的丈夫在她的儿子还只有 13 岁时就去世了。所以她以摄政王的身份统治。我的意思是，她负责那个王国的运作。你还有奥托的妻子，一个叫阿德莱德（Adelaide）的女人，她是勃艮第国王的女儿，那是那些王国之一，洛泰林吉亚，在中间。当奥托在罗马被加冕和涂油时，她也与他一起被加冕和涂油。
who has the brilliant name Gerberger okay she marries king of what will become france so if you think of you know there's the german kingdom and there's the what let's call it the french kingdom yeah frankish kingdom and she marries the king has eight children by him but her husband dies while her son is is still only 13 And so she rules as regent. I mean, she is responsible for the running of that kingdom. And you also have Otto's wife, who is a woman called Adelaide, and she is the daughter of the King of Burgundy, which is one of those kind of kingdoms, Lotharingia, kind of down the middle. And when Otto is crowned in Rome and anointed, she is crowned and anointed alongside him.
所以她是一位皇后。她是一位女皇（Imperatrix），一位女皇奥古斯塔（Imperatrix Augusta）。狄奥法诺也是如此。狄奥法诺也有同样的情况。这种认为王后可以被祝圣，这种圣油将她们提升到一种神圣不可侵犯的地位的想法，不仅仅是国王从中受益，他们的王后和女皇也一样。这然后，我可以说是“神圣化”吗？听起来你打算这么说。
So she is an empress. She is an imperatrix, an imperatrix Augusta. And so is Theophano. Theophano has the same thing. And this idea that queens can be consecrated, that this holy oil, which elevates them to a kind of a sacrosanct status, it's not just kings who are benefiting from that. Their queens and their empresses do as well. And this then, can I say, sacralises? Sounds like you're going to.
她们在宫廷中扮演的角色，因为宫廷里没有什么是私人的。女性所做的一切，特别是如果她是王后，都是公开的。她的职责是向丈夫代求，请求怜悯，照顾病人，向穷人分发施舍，负责编织装饰牧师和教堂的法衣和挂毯。这一切都非常、非常公开。王后扮演的角色对国王有巨大的影响，所以如果王后很糟糕，或者到处乱搞，或者失去了名声，那么这对国王的影响非常不好。是的，但同样，如果她因虔诚和关心臣民而受到尊重，那么这对国王来说太棒了，绝对太棒了。显然我感觉到王后权力的上升
The role that they play in the court, because nothing in a court is private. Everything that a woman does, especially if she's the queen, is public. It's her role to intercede with her husband, to ask for mercy, to care for the sick, to distribute arms to the poor, to be responsible for the weaving of the vestments and the tapestries that will adorn the priests and the churches. And it's all very, very public. And the role played by the queen reflects massively on the king so if the queen is kind of rubbish or sleeping around or loses her reputation then that reflects very badly yeah but equally if she is respected for her piety and as someone who cares for her subjects then that's brilliant for the king absolutely brilliant and obviously i get the sense of a rise in the power of queens
在这一时期，但你是在争论，或者有一种观点认为这是新的。是的。女性被赋予了比 8 世纪或 7 世纪等时期更多的权力。因为例如，东罗马帝国曾有过女性统治者。曾有过伊琳娜（Irene）等等。嗯，我们会谈到这一点。所以我们现在只是在谈论法兰克传统，以及盎格鲁-撒克逊传统。但在拉丁西方，王后的相对地位确实在上升。所以有一位编年史家谈到强大的女性，不仅仅是王后，我是说，还有贵族，这个世界里强大的女性，奥托宫廷，当她周围的人站着时，她却坐着。所以这种认为她是“女领主”（domina），一位女性领主，我想，但不仅仅是一位女士。一个“领主”（dominus）是
in this period, but you're arguing that, or there is an argument that this is new. Yes. That women are being given more power than in the eighth or seventh century or whatever. Because there had been, for example, women rulers in the Eastern Roman empire. There'd been Irene and so on and so forth. Well, we'll come to that. So we're just talking about the Frankish traditions at this point, and indeed the Anglo-Saxon traditions too. But in the Latin West, definitely there is a rise in the relative status of queens. So there's a chronicler who says about powerful, it's not just queens, I mean, it's aristocrats as well, the powerful women in this world, the Etonian court, they sit while all around her people stand. So this idea that she is a domina, a female lord, a lady, I suppose, but it's more than a lady. A dominus is
几乎超过了皇帝。这是一个拥有巨大权力的形象。所以圣母是一位“女领主”。她是天堂的“女领主”。在某种意义上，王后们扮演着圣母的角色，我们将看到这是狄奥法诺大加利用的东西，我认为这部分与神学变化、关于涂油的概念等等有关，但我认为这也是一个简单的事实，即男人比女人更容易死亡，因为他们在战斗，他们在狩猎，他们在做疯狂的事情，互相投掷骨头。所以这意味着女性，因为这种神圣不可侵犯的地位，能够扮演摄政王的角色，就像格伯格所做的那样。那么你知道在这一时期谁做了这件事吗？圣奥尔加（St. Olga）。
almost more than an emperor. It's a figure of enormous power. So the virgin is a domina. She is the domina of heaven. And there's a sense in which queens are kind of playing the part of the virgin and we will see that this is something that theophany makes great play with and i think it's partly to do with kind of theological changes notions about anointing and and all that but i think it's also the simple fact that men are likelier to die than women because they're fighting they're hunting they, they're doing mad things, kind of throwing bones at each other. And so this then means that women, because of this sacrosanct status, are able to play a role as regents, as Gebirge does. So do you know who did that at this exact period? St. Olga.
没错。基辅的奥尔加。她的丈夫去世了。我想他被德列夫利安人（Derevlians）撕成了碎片。是的。她最终在一个非常男性化的世界里成为了摄政王，那个基辅罗斯的世界。所以同样，一个女性在扮演角色，因为她有经验。嗯，她其实没有。她还很年轻。
That's right. Olga of Kiev. Her husband died. He was torn apart by, I think, the Derevlians. Yes. And she ended up as regent in a very masculine world, the world of the kind of the Rus in Kiev. So again, a woman playing because she's experienced. Well, she's actually not. She's quite young.
但因为她不会在战斗中死去，对吧？嗯，她是一个拥有可怕权力的形象。是的。我的意思是，你知道，用鸟类俯冲轰炸城镇等等。是的。活埋人，各种恶作剧。是的。所有那种东西。
But because she's not going to die in battle, right? Well, she's a figure of terrifying power. Yeah. I mean, you know, kind of dive-bonging towns with birds and all kinds of things. Yeah. Burying people alive, all kinds of japes. Yes. All that kind of stuff.
是的。所以这是一个时期，在基辅，或在英格兰，或在法国，或在后来变成德国的地方，如果需要，女性被期望扮演这个角色。是的。你知道，如果统治者太年轻什么的。所以这就在 973 年奥托大帝去世时引发了一种有趣的紧张关系。所以就在他的儿子小奥托（现在成为奥托二世）娶了狄奥法诺一年后。当然，背景中潜伏着阿德莱德，奥托大帝的妻子。
Yeah. So this is a period where in Kiev or in England or in France or in what will become Germany, women are expected to play this role if required. Yeah. You know, if a ruler is too young or whatever. And so this then sets up an intriguing tension when in 973, Otto the Great dies. So barely a year after his son, Otto Jr., who now becomes Otto II, has married Theophanu. And of course, you have lurking in the background, Adelaide, Otto the Great's wife.
是的。她会期望自己扮演关键角色，因为狄奥法诺当时才 15、16 岁。是的。在这一点上。所以问题是，她的角色会是什么？她能够为自己开辟一个独特的角色吗？还是她会被那位傲慢的前女皇和勃艮第国王的女儿完全掩盖？
Yeah. Who would have the expectation that she should play the key role because Theophano is still 15, 16. Yeah. At this point. And so the question then is, what is her role going to be? Is she going to be able to carve out a distinctive role for herself? Or is she going to be put firmly in the shadow by the imperious ex-empress and daughter of
多么戏剧性。我想我们应该在下半场找到答案。多么悬念。Chiara，在意大利语中是“聪明”的意思。可惜你的咖啡师拼不对。所以你只能报个假名，你的咖啡馆名字，朱莉娅。但用得越久，就越觉得自己像是在接受证人保护。
the King of Burgundy? What drama. And I think we should find out when we the King of Burgundy. What drama. And I think we should find out when we come to the second half. What a cliffhanger. Chiara, it means smart in Italian. Too bad your barista can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection.
等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改点拿铁还来得及吗？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了。因为你完全可以在家自制浓缩咖啡。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this. Because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。汤姆，紧张气氛从未如此强烈。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. The tension has never been greater, Tom.
我们即将了解狄奥法诺在她的公公——萨克森的伟大硬汉、自视为西方凯撒的奥托大帝去世后所扮演的角色。在我们了解狄奥法诺的表现之前，我可以问你，我们对她此时的个性有什么了解吗？有相互矛盾的报道，我认为这些相互矛盾的报道反映了一个事实，即有相互矛盾的派系，他们有理由强调某一方面。所以我认为很难掌握她作为一个真实的人是什么样的。但我认为，正如我们将从她的表现、她的记录中看到的那样，我们可以确定一件事：她非常能干，因为我的意思是，她处于一个非常棘手的境地。
We're about to find out the role that Theophanu plays after the death of her father-in-law, Otto the Great, the great hard man of Saxony who sees himself as a Caesar in the West. Just before we find out how Theophanu does, can I ask you, do we have any sense of her personality at this point? There are contradictory reports, and I think these contradictory reports reflect the fact that there are contradictory factions who have reasons to emphasize one thing or another. So I think it is very difficult to get a handle on what she was like as an actual person. But I think that as we will see from her performance, her record, one thing we can be sure of, she is awesomely competent because, I mean, she's in a very tricky position.
她是个外国人。她是个青少年。她有一位令人极其畏惧的婆婆。她可能不会说这种语言。我的意思是，这是一个尴尬的处境。然而，好处是她是皇帝的受膏妻子，一位女皇奥古斯塔。所以她有空间去利用我们之前谈到的所有事情，这种萨克森宫廷及其他地方的人们愿意
She's a foreigner. She's a teenager. She has a massively intimidating mother-in-law. She probably doesn't speak the language. I mean, it's an awkward position to be in. However, the upside is that she is the anointed wife of an emperor, an imperatrix Augusta. And so she has scope to make play with all the things that we were talking about before, this sense that people in the Saxon court and beyond are willing
她是个外国人，是个十几岁的少女，还有一位极其令人生畏的婆婆。她可能还不会说当地语言。我的意思是，这处境非常尴尬。然而，好的一面是她是皇帝钦定的妻子，一位奥古斯塔皇后。因此，她有空间去利用我们之前谈到的所有因素，即萨克森宫廷内外的人们都愿意支持她。
to allow a powerful woman a chance to do her stuff. And I think the fact that she is a foreigner actually works to her advantage because it's pretty clear that the Saxons aren't entirely sure what to make of her. So there are certainly those who are suspicious of her and resentful of her. So you asked, how do people think of her? There are people who say she talks too much, that this is a very Greek thing. So they talk of her insolent prattling. But there are others who say, you know, this is a tremendously serious, solemn and modest woman. And then Chronicler adds, which is of course a rare thing in a Greek. So I think you see there the sense that her behavior is obviously not Saxon,
让一位强大的女性有机会施展才华。我认为她作为外国人的事实实际上对她有利，因为很明显，撒克逊人并不完全确定该如何看待她。所以肯定有人对她心存怀疑和怨恨。你问人们怎么看她？有人说她话太多，这非常希腊化。所以他们谈论她那傲慢的喋喋不休。但也有人说，你知道，这是一位非常严肃、庄重且谦逊的女性。然后编年史家补充道，这在希腊人中当然是罕见的。所以我认为你从中可以看出，她的行为显然不是撒克逊式的，
but the very fact that she is distinctive, that she brings a different way of understanding things helps her. And I think this is really important because obviously she is distinctive, that she brings a different way of understanding things, helps her. And I think this is really important because obviously she does have, she has enemies of whom Adelaide is the most notable. Adelaide hates her. She refers to Theophanu as that Greek woman, that Greek girl. She never calls her by name. And to begin with, she is very determined that her son, Otto II, is going to remain firmly under her thumb.
但她与众不同、能带来一种不同的理解事物方式的事实确实对她有帮助。我认为这非常重要，因为显然她确实有敌人，其中阿德莱德最为显眼。阿德莱德讨厌她。她称塞奥法诺为“那个希腊女人”、“那个希腊女孩”。她从不直呼其名。起初，她非常坚定地认为她的儿子奥托二世将牢牢地掌握在自己手中。
So she follows the happy couple everywhere that they go. She is essentially trying to rule as regent. And Theophanu is having none of this. And within a year of her husband becoming king, she and Adelaide having massive bust-ups about whether Adelaide can use the lands that she has in Germany to further Adelaide's own purposes. And basically, Theophanie wins that. And the sense of a kind of a massive cleavage in the heart of the Ottonian court is heightened by the fact that there is another big adversary that not just Theophanie, but her husband
所以她跟着这对幸福的夫妇到处走。她本质上是想以摄政王的身份统治。而塞奥法诺对此完全不买账。在丈夫成为国王的一年内，她和阿德莱德就阿德莱德是否可以利用她在德国的土地来推进阿德莱德自己的目的而发生了激烈的争吵。基本上，塞奥法诺赢了。奥托尼亚宫廷核心地带出现巨大裂痕的感觉，因为奥托二世不仅有塞奥法诺，还有另一个强大的对手，这种感觉被加剧了。
Otto II has. And this is Otto II's uncle,'s the duke of bavaria who rejoices in the brilliant name of henry the quarrelsome and he is indeed quarrelsome and there's just kind of endless rows it's all about who gets to appoint bishops all that kind of stuff i mean the details aren't that important right basically he wants to become the duke of swabia i mean basically he wants to become the king and thereabia. I mean, basically he wants to become the king. And there are all kinds of bust-ups throughout the 970s. Otto is endlessly imprisoning Henry the Quarrelsome, letting him go, imprisoning him again. And by 976, there's been open warfare. Henry the Quarrelsome
那就是奥托二世的叔叔，巴伐利亚公爵，他拥有“好斗者亨利”这个响亮的名字，他确实很好斗，总是没完没了的争吵，都是关于谁有权任命主教之类的琐事，我的意思是细节并不重要，基本上他想成为士瓦本公爵，我的意思是基本上他想成为国王。在970年代，到处都是争吵。奥托不断地监禁好斗者亨利，释放他，然后再次监禁他。到了976年，已经爆发了公开战争。好斗者亨利
has been captured, handed over to the Bishop of Utrecht, who keeps him in prison for the rest of Otto II's life. And I think that this definitely damages Adelaide because she is seen as having been aligned with Henry the Quarrelsome. And I think that really helps Theophanu's status. And of course, the other thing that helps Theophanu is that it's not just her personal qualities, but as you were kind of alluding to in the first half, that she is the embodiment of a much more sophisticated court than the Saxon court. And that of course is the court at Constantinople. And there are Saxon noblemen who side with Henry the Quarrelsome and Adelaide against Theophanu, who resent it, who basically say Otto II has gone Greek. You know, he's no longer one of the lads.
被俘虏，交给了乌得勒支主教，他在奥托二世的余生中一直将他关在监狱里。我认为这肯定损害了阿德莱德的形象，因为她被视为与好斗者亨利结盟。我认为这确实提升了塞奥法诺的地位。当然，另一件帮助塞奥法诺的事情是，这不仅仅是因为她个人的品质，正如你在前半部分所暗示的那样，她是一个比撒克逊宫廷复杂得多的宫廷的化身。那当然就是君士坦丁堡的宫廷。有些撒克逊贵族站在好斗者亨利和阿德莱德一边反对塞奥法诺，他们对此感到怨恨，基本上说奥托二世已经“希腊化”了。你知道，他不再是那些小伙子中的一员了。
He's no longer kind of cracking open bones and gnawing out the marrow and throwing it at people and japing. I mean, it's a bit like what people say about Prince Harry. He used to be a lad and now he's gone all weird with his foreign wife. So it's kind of slightly like that. But what Theophanu can provide is basically what Otto the Great had wanted, which is a sheen of class. Prestige. Roman prestige. Yeah. Sophistication. So she has a massive influence on the way the court behaves. So she brings all these kind of silk robes, all these jewels. I mean, no one in Saxony has seen anything like it. She takes a daily bath. Unheard of. of i mean charlemagne liked to bath but people are not normally taking a bath every day absolute scenes and very famously she introduces
他不再像以前那样敲开骨头啃食骨髓，把它扔向别人，或者开玩笑了。我的意思是，这有点像人们谈论哈里王子的方式。他曾经是个小伙子，现在却因为娶了个外国妻子而变得古怪。所以有点像那样。但塞奥法诺能提供的是大帝奥托所渴望的东西，那就是一种阶级的华丽。威望。罗马的威望。是的。精致。所以她对宫廷的行为方式产生了巨大的影响。她带来了所有这些丝绸长袍，所有这些珠宝。我的意思是，萨克森没有人见过这样的东西。她每天洗澡。闻所未闻。我的意思是查理曼大帝喜欢洗澡，但人们通常不会每天洗澡，这简直是奇观，而且非常著名的是，她引入了
to the table the dining table a fascinating new ornament so it's described as a golden double prong which brings food to the mouth by a chronicler so So it's a fork. The inventor of the fork. But she doesn't invent it. I mean, the Byzantines have it, but she brings it. Yeah. I'll be frank with you. I don't believe that people in Western Europe had never seen forks before. I mean, it's a golden fork that she has, isn't it?
餐桌上一种迷人的新装饰，被编年史家描述为一种将食物送入口中的金色双齿叉。所以，这就是叉子。叉子的发明者。但她并不是发明者。我的意思是，拜占庭人有叉子，但她把它带了过来。是的。坦白说，我不相信西欧人以前从未见过叉子。我的意思是，她用的是金叉，不是吗？
I'm less skeptical. Because I think you'd use a fork for spitting and roasting things. You might use a sword, but it's a double prong, isn't it? Double prong. That's the key. Thank God she didn't have a fork with three prongs. That would have been really shocking. I know. I wonder who introduced that. But it's not just manners, obviously. It's the way of being an emperor that in Constantinople is the legacy of centuries and centuries of Roman ritual. And part of that, again, as you suggested, is that this emphasis in the Latin West on the sacral role played by queens and empresses.
我没那么怀疑。因为我认为你会用叉子来叉肉和烤肉。你可能会用剑，但那是双齿的，不是吗？双齿。那是关键。谢天谢地，她没有用三齿叉。那会非常令人震惊。我知道。我想知道是谁引入了那个。但这显然不仅仅是礼仪。这是一种作为皇帝的方式，在君士坦丁堡，这是几个世纪以来罗马仪式的遗产。正如你所建议的那样，这其中的一部分是拉丁西方对王后和皇后所扮演的神圣角色的强调。
With Theophanu, it fuses with a kind of Byzantine sense that the empress is the counterpart of the emperor, that that is her role. And I think that Theophanu obviously completely buys into this. And it's an approach that fuses very easily with what she finds in the Latin West, but elevates and dignifies it. It's even grander than anything that Adelaide had known. And Theophanu is able to carry it off because she clearly has a kind of incredible sense of theatre, of dignity, of poise, of sophistication. And I think that lots of Saxons love this because they are aware that
在塞奥法诺身上，这与一种拜占庭式的观念融合在一起，即皇后是皇帝的对应者，这就是她的角色。我认为塞奥法诺显然完全接受了这一点。这种方法很容易与她在拉丁西方发现的东西融合，但提升并尊严化了它。它甚至比阿德莱德所知道的任何东西都要宏大。塞奥法诺能够做到这一点，因为她显然有一种令人难以置信的戏剧感、尊严感、风度和精致感。我认为很多撒克逊人喜欢这一点，因为他们意识到
the emperor in Constantinople traditionally has looked down on the Franks as barbarians. Yeah. So when Leoprand of Cremona goes to ask Nikephoros at the beginning, can we have a princess and gets rebuffed? I mean, he's full of complaints that all the snubs he gets, you know, he's, he's sat beneath a Bulgarian, he's given bad food. He's not given good accommodation. He complains that the Greeks are soft, effeminate, long-sleeved, hooded, veiled, lying, gender fluid, idle creatures. And then to rub salt into his wounds, all the silks that he's bought in the market in Constantinople get confiscated by customs officials. So massive, massive resentment. But he'd been 18 years earlier and had a splendid
君士坦丁堡的皇帝传统上一直把法兰克人视为野蛮人。是的。所以当克雷莫纳的利乌特普兰德一开始去问尼基弗鲁斯，我们能得到一位公主吗，却被拒绝时？我的意思是，他满腹牢骚，抱怨他受到的所有冷遇，你知道，他坐在保加利亚人下面，被给予糟糕的食物。他没有得到好的住宿。他抱怨希腊人是软弱、女性化、长袖、戴兜帽、戴面纱、撒谎、性别流动、懒惰的生物。然后为了在他的伤口上撒盐，他在君士坦丁堡市场上买的所有丝绸都被海关官员没收了。所以有巨大的、巨大的怨恨。但他18年前去过那里，度过了一段辉煌的
time, hosted by a much friendlier emperor. And he'd loved it. And he'd been invited in, he'd reclined on a couch like an ancient Roman, eating sumptuous meals off golden dishes. All kinds of organs spring up from the floor. Gold dishes of fruit descend from the ceiling. There's a kind of weird thing. There's a strong man who he balances a kind of a pole on his forehead and kind of two young lads run up and down this pole doing magic tricks. I mean, it's very weird. And you'd think that that was made up, but you get the same thing from the court of the Caliphs. It's clearly a kind of Middle Eastern imperial thing that's done. Leoprand of Cremona thinks this is tremendous. So I think you get in him what's going on. It's this blend of admiration, fascination, and resentment. Classic cultural cringe, right?
时光，受到了一位更友好的皇帝的款待。他很喜欢。他被邀请进去，像古罗马人一样躺在长椅上，在金盘子上吃着丰盛的饭菜。各种各样的管风琴从地板上冒出来。水果金盘从天花板上降下来。有一种奇怪的东西。有一个大力士，他在额头上平衡一根杆子，两个小伙子在这根杆子上跑来跑去表演魔术。我的意思是，这非常奇怪。你会认为那是编造的，但你在哈里发宫廷里也会看到同样的东西。这显然是一种中东帝国的习俗。克雷莫纳的利乌特普兰德认为这太棒了。所以我认为你在他身上看到了正在发生的事情。这是一种钦佩、迷恋和怨恨的混合体。典型的文化自卑，对吧？
Absolutely. And so Theophanu is elegant, she's silken, she's bejeweled, and she gives to Otto a kind of a touch of the glamour of Constantinople. And Otto, of course, absolutely loves this. And it enables her to become a really heavyweight player in the game of court politics. So she sees off Adelaide, who ends up retiring to Burgundy. She accompanies her husband everywhere. She is seen as someone who it's worth approaching. She's playing that classic role of the queen who intercedes with her husband. Yeah.
绝对是。所以塞奥法诺优雅、丝绸般、珠光宝气，她给了奥托一种君士坦丁堡的魅力。奥托当然非常喜欢这一点。这使她能够成为宫廷政治博弈中一个非常有分量的参与者。所以她送走了最终退隐到勃艮第的阿德莱德。她陪着丈夫去任何地方。她被视为一个值得接近的人。她扮演了那个经典的王后角色，在丈夫面前代人求情。是的。
And she's very, very influential on table manners. So everyone's using forks now. Little golden forks, exactly. Huge increase in court splend splendor and i think a very interesting change in the way that the virgin mary is presented so we talked about how the virgin is seen as the domina of the court of of heaven it's in this period that the virgin starts to be portrayed as a byzantine empress so with the jewels and the silks right which is obviously a reflection of how theophano is presenting herself and giving Otto all this kind of, you know, this sense of class. And then in 980, she absolutely does her duty by giving him
她对餐桌礼仪非常有影响力。所以现在每个人都在用叉子。小金叉，没错。宫廷的辉煌程度大大增加，我认为圣母玛利亚的呈现方式也有一个非常有趣的改变，所以我们谈到了圣母是如何被视为天堂宫廷的女主人的，正是在这个时期，圣母开始被描绘成一位拜占庭皇后，带着珠宝和丝绸，这显然反映了塞奥法诺是如何展示自己并赋予奥托这种阶级感的。然后在980年，她通过为他生下
a son. And Dominic, can you guess what the son of Otto II, the son of Otto I is called? Otto, of course. Yeah, it is. It's going to be Otto, isn't it? It is. A lot of Ottos. So this is great. So Otto is feeling, you know, by 980, he's got a son. He's seen off Henry the Quarrelsome. He's got a brilliant wife. He's classy. He's got his fork. Having a bath. Absolutely brilliant. Living the dream. And he feels that he's now ready to cross the Alps and reassert his authority over Italy in the way that his father had done.
一个儿子，绝对尽到了她的职责。多米尼克，你能猜出奥托一世的儿子、奥托二世的儿子叫什么名字吗？当然是奥托。是的，确实是。肯定是奥托，不是吗？是的。有很多奥托。这太棒了。所以奥托觉得，到980年，他有了一个儿子。他送走了好斗者亨利。他有一位出色的妻子。他很有格调。他有他的叉子。还在洗澡。绝对太棒了。过着梦想中的生活。他觉得他现在准备好越过阿尔卑斯山，像他父亲那样重申他对意大利的权威。
Because obviously as an emperor of the Romans, it's a bit embarrassing if you can't actually rule in Rome. And to be an emperor... He's got to be crowned. So Tom, big question. Has he been crowned emperor? Because you have to be crowned in Rome, don't you, to become emperor? Otherwise you're just king. He has been. He was crowned while his father was still alive, as Theophany was as well. Ah, interesting. So that's why she is an imperatrix, he is an imperator. Yeah. They are an imperial couple.
因为显然作为罗马人的皇帝，如果你不能真正在罗马统治，那有点尴尬。要成为皇帝……他必须加冕。所以汤姆，大问题。他被加冕为皇帝了吗？因为你必须在罗马加冕，不是吗，才能成为皇帝？否则你只是国王。他已经加冕了。他在他父亲还活着的时候就被加冕了，塞奥法诺也是。啊，有趣。所以这就是为什么她是女皇，他是皇帝。是的。他们是一对帝国夫妇。
But of course, you can't really be an emperor of the Romans if you're not sat in Rome. Yeah. So that's why he goes there. He crosses the Alps in November 980. By spring, he has arrived in Rome. He's holding court. And I think it is hard not to feel that the presence beside him of Theophanu, a princess from the new Rome, from the city of Constantine,
但当然，如果你不坐在罗马，你就不能真正成为罗马人的皇帝。是的。所以这就是他去那里的原因。他在980年11月越过阿尔卑斯山。到春天，他已经到达罗马。他在那里举行朝廷。我认为很难不感觉到塞奥法诺，这位来自新罗马、来自君士坦丁之城的公主在他身边的存在，
kind of raises his horizons, expands his horizons, and makes him think he would like to rule more completely as a Caesar than his father had done. And to rule as a Caesar kind of requires you to rule Italy. I mean, this is the homeland of the Roman Empire. And essentially this becomes his plan. He's going to conquer Italy. Now there are two massive problems with this because there are two very, very menacing adversaries in the South. And the first of these, of course, is Byzantium. Yeah, because if Italy is to be Roman, which Rome? Right, exactly. And actually, Otto the Great and the Byzantine garrisons in the south, they'd actually been fighting each other about a decade before. Obviously, the peace treaty with John Simitskis had sorted that out. Theophanu had arrived. You'd think it would be peace.
提高了他的视野，扩展了他的视野，并让他认为他想比他父亲更彻底地以凯撒的身份统治。而要以凯撒的身份统治，某种程度上要求你统治意大利。我的意思是，这是罗马帝国的故乡。基本上这成了他的计划。他要征服意大利。现在这有两个巨大的问题，因为南方有两个非常、非常危险的对手。第一个当然是拜占庭。是的，因为如果意大利要成为罗马的，那是哪个罗马？没错，正是如此。实际上，大帝奥托和南方的拜占庭驻军在大约十年前还在互相争斗。显然，与约翰·齐米斯基斯的和平条约解决了这个问题。塞奥法诺已经到达。你会认为那会是和平。
So how can he possibly think of going to war with Byzantium? Well, the answer is, is that John Smitsky by this point has been himself assassinated and replaced, poisoned by a eunuch, it is claimed. And Theophanu is incredibly hostile to the murderers of her uncle-in-law and is clearly encouraging Otto to go down and have a crack at it. Ah, right. Of course. So presumably Theophany herself is thinking, you know, let's start by kicking these usurpers out of Italy, but then why not go on? Why not become empress of a reunited Roman empire? And she is now the mother of a son who has the blood of the imperial families, both of Constantinople and of Rome in his veins. So, you know, why not? Let's reunite the Roman empire. So that's all very exciting. And I think that Theophany is undoubtedly influencing Otto in his, you know, his kind of ambitions for this.
那么他怎么可能想到与拜占庭开战呢？嗯，答案是，约翰·齐米斯基斯此时已经被暗杀并被取代，据称是被一名太监毒死的。塞奥法诺对她叔叔的谋杀者极其敌视，显然在鼓励奥托下去给他们一点教训。啊，对。当然。所以大概塞奥法诺自己也在想，你知道，让我们从把这些篡位者赶出意大利开始，但为什么不继续呢？为什么不成为统一的罗马帝国的女皇呢？她现在是一个儿子的母亲，这个儿子的血管里流淌着君士坦丁堡和罗马两个帝国家族的血液。所以，你知道，为什么不呢？让我们统一罗马帝国。所以这一切都非常令人兴奋。我认为塞奥法诺无疑在影响奥托的这种野心。
But of course there are also non-Christian, non-Roman enemies, and that is the Saracens, the Fatimid Caliphate. There are various emirs, subordinate rulers in Sicily, who in turn sponsor the various pirate fleets that are sailing up the seaboard of Italy and just stripping Italy bare. So all the old Roman cities, basically by this point, have been abandoned because it's too dangerous. And if you think about people who've driven through Italy, often, particularly in the South, villages and towns that are up on hills, they're not down on the plains where they had been in the Roman period. And that's because you have to be up there because otherwise you're going to be taken away as a slave. They have unbelievably sophisticated
但当然还有非基督教、非罗马的敌人，那就是萨拉森人，法蒂玛哈里发国。西西里岛有各种埃米尔，即下属统治者，他们反过来资助各种航行在意大利海岸线上并洗劫意大利的海盗船队。所以所有的古罗马城市，基本上到这个时候都已经被遗弃了，因为太危险了。如果你想到那些开车穿过意大利的人，通常，特别是在南方，村庄和城镇都在山上，而不是像罗马时期那样在平原上。这是因为你必须待在那里，否则你会被抓走当奴隶。他们有令人难以置信的复杂
slaving operations. They have people who take on different roles in the process of enslavement, of rounding people up. And they've been menacing Rome itself. They've kind of sacked St. Peter's at one point. And I think Otto also is worried that there seems to be a swelling of Saracen power in this period, that the pirates are becoming more active and he's afraid for Rome. So it's also about having kind of preemptive strike at them. And they're striking from Sicily, right? They're striking up the coast from Sicily. Yeah. So January 982, Otto heads off at the head of a kind of great army of what are called loricati, armored horsemen, and Theophanu is riding with him. They cross into Byzantine territory and Otto says to the Byzantine garrisons, I come as a Christian, I come as a Caesar, I come as a Roman, join with me, let's pool our resources and go and
奴隶贸易行动。他们有人在奴役、围捕人的过程中扮演不同的角色。他们一直在威胁罗马本身。他们有一次洗劫了圣彼得大教堂。我认为奥托也很担心，因为在这个时期萨拉森人的力量似乎在膨胀，海盗变得更加活跃，他为罗马感到担忧。所以这也是关于对他们进行某种先发制人的打击。他们是从西西里岛发动袭击的，对吧？他们正沿着海岸从西西里岛发动袭击。是的。所以982年1月，奥托率领一支被称为“盔甲骑兵”的庞大军队出发，塞奥法诺也和他一起骑马。他们进入了拜占庭领土，奥托对拜占庭驻军说，我以基督徒的身份而来，我以凯撒的身份而来，我以罗马人的身份而来，加入我，让我们汇集资源，去
attack the Saracens in Sicily. The Byzantine garrisons refuse. Otto loses his patience. He invests Tarento, which is under Byzantine rule, captures it, and then formally proclaims himself emperor of the entire Roman world. And his justification for this is that the Byzantines are cowardly, that they have refused to join him in this great war. Therefore, they no longer have any right to the name of Roman. They no longer deserve to rank as the shield of Christendom. Otto now should rule as sole emperor. So an important question. Is that just performative, as it were? Is that just, he knows it's good pr or does he genuinely think
攻击西西里岛的萨拉森人。拜占庭驻军拒绝了。奥托失去了耐心。他围攻了处于拜占庭统治下的塔兰托，占领了它，然后正式宣布自己为整个罗马世界的皇帝。他对此的辩护是，拜占庭人是懦夫，他们拒绝加入他的这场伟大战争。因此，他们不再有任何权利使用罗马人的名字。他们不再配得上作为基督教世界的盾牌。奥托现在应该作为唯一的皇帝统治。所以一个重要的问题。这只是表演性的吗？这只是，他知道这公关效果好，还是他真的认为
that within the short to medium term he will unite the two hours of the roman empire again i think the latter for reasons we'll come to at the end of this show and it's massively influenced by theophanie okay i think that theophanie has a properly pan-mediterranean vision she is familiar with constantinople she's Constantinople, she's familiar with Rome, she's familiar with Saxony. I think that she, for reasons that are not entirely geopolitical but theological, will come to that particular reason. I think she does think a time is approaching when the whole Roman Empire will be reunited. Unfortunately, it doesn't go well and Otto's attempt to defeat the Saracens is a complete disaster. So in July,
在短期到中期内，他将再次统一罗马帝国的两个部分？我认为是后者，原因我们将在本节目结束时提到，而且这在很大程度上受到了塞奥法诺的影响。好的，我认为塞奥法诺有一种真正的泛地中海视野，她熟悉君士坦丁堡，她熟悉罗马，她熟悉萨克森。我认为她，出于并非完全是地缘政治而是神学的原因，我们会谈到那个特定的原因。我认为她确实认为统一整个罗马帝国的时刻即将来临。不幸的是，事情进展不顺，奥托试图击败萨拉森人的尝试是一场彻底的灾难。所以在七月，
they meet with a massive Saracen fleet and army. Otto is defeated. He has to escape the battlefield, borrows a horse from a passing Jew, rides it out into the sea, gets picked up by Byzantine galley. Very, very humiliating. Yeah, his enemies. Yeah, so Otto says to the guy who's picked him up, let us hope that your emperor, my brother, will be a loyal friend to me in my time of need. Whoa, you've changed your tune.
他们遇到了一支庞大的萨拉森舰队和军队。奥托被击败了。他不得不逃离战场，从一个路过的犹太人那里借了一匹马，骑着它冲进海里，被一艘拜占庭桨帆船救起。非常、非常丢脸。是的，他的敌人。是的，所以奥托对救起他的人说，让我们希望你的皇帝，我的兄弟，在我需要的时候会成为我忠诚的朋友。哇，你改变了口吻。
Yeah, he's changed his tune. And he gets rode back and he meets up with Theophanu. And Theophanu is furious with him, kind of bollocks him and says that her countrymen would never have been so rash. Okay. This doesn't bode well for the Ottonians becoming masters of the Roman world. If she's saying, you know, the Easterners would never have made this total horlicks of the operation. Yeah. So it all goes horribly wrong from this point on. Fortunately, the Sicilian battle leader, the Emir, has fallen in his hour of victory, which means that the Saracen onslaught is not
是的，他改变了口吻。他被带了回来，见到了塞奥法诺。塞奥法诺对他非常愤怒，训斥了他，说她的同胞绝不会如此鲁莽。好的。如果她说，你知道，东方人绝不会把这次行动搞得一团糟，那么这对奥托尼亚人成为罗马世界的主人来说不是好兆头。是的。所以从这一点开始，一切都变得非常糟糕。幸运的是，西西里岛的战斗领袖，那位埃米尔，在胜利时刻阵亡了，这意味着萨拉森人的猛攻并没有
as devastating as it would otherwise have been. But it means that Otto has to stay in Italy to shore up the defences of Rome and northern Italy against Saracen raids. And meanwhile, up in Germany, of course, the news has arrived in Saxony and it's crossed the river Elbe to the Slavs, the Wens in particular. Yeah. The guys who, whenever they want to know what's going to happen, ask a horse. We've talked about them before. And they seize their opportunity and they rise in rebellion and they overthrow Ottonian power. They burn all the churches that have been built there, you know, and that's it.
像原本可能的那样具有毁灭性。但这确实意味着奥托必须留在意大利，以加强罗马和意大利北部的防御，抵御萨拉森人的袭击。与此同时，在德国，当然，消息已经传到了萨克森，并越过易北河传到了斯拉夫人，特别是温德人那里。是的。那些无论想知道会发生什么，都会问马的人。我们之前谈过他们。他们抓住了机会，发动了叛乱，推翻了奥托尼亚的统治。他们烧毁了那里建造的所有教堂，你知道，就是这样。
And the Danes get stuck in as well, don't they? The Danes attack Schleswig. Danes get stuck in. well, don't they? The Danes attack Schleswig. Danes get stuck in. Yeah, the Schleswig-Holstein question breaks out. They're attacking. And it's, you know, it's all a disaster. It's a measure, I think, of Otto's trust in Theophanu that he sends her north of the Alps to try and sort the situation out while he is busy in Italy trying to stabilize the situation
丹麦人也卷入了，不是吗？丹麦人袭击了石勒苏益格。丹麦人卷入了。是的，石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因问题爆发了。他们在进攻。而且，你知道，这一切都是一场灾难。我认为，奥托对塞奥法诺的信任程度从他派她到阿尔卑斯山以北去试图解决局势中可见一斑，而他则忙于在意大利试图稳定那里的局势。
there. And Theophanu takes her three-year Italy trying to stabilize the situation there. And the orphan who takes her three-year-old son, the infant Otto, there's been a kind of stage managed election. He's been named co-emperor with his dad, big kind of dyer to Verona. And then she goes north. She goes to Aachen where the throne of Charlemagne, great palace of Charlemagne. And again, the little boy is crowned there. So she's, you know, she's still very into her ritual, her crowns, all that kind of thing. And then the crisis gets worse because on the 7th of December, Otto dies in Italy of malaria.
塞奥法诺带着她三岁的儿子，幼年的奥托，进行了一场精心策划的选举。他被任命为与他父亲共同的皇帝，在维罗纳举行了盛大的仪式。然后她去了北方。她去了亚琛，那里有查理曼大帝的宝座，查理曼大帝的伟大宫殿。那个小男孩也在那里加冕。所以她，你知道，她仍然非常热衷于她的仪式、她的皇冠，所有这些事情。然后危机变得更糟，因为12月7日，奥托在意大利死于疟疾。
And is buried in St. Peter's and actually is the only Holy Roman Emperor to be buried in Rome. So, you know, the situation seems completely hopeless. You've got Saracens in the south, you've got the Wends have rebelled. You've got all these fractious noblemen. You've got a three-year-old boy on the throne, scavengers everywhere, looks disaster. But Theophanus steadies the ship and more than steadies the ship. She makes Saxony. Great again. You know, she stabilizes the frontiers. She patches up treaties with the Swedes, with the Danes, with Vladimir the Great in Kiev.
他被安葬在圣彼得大教堂，实际上是唯一一位被安葬在罗马的神圣罗马帝国皇帝。所以，你知道，局势看起来完全绝望。南方有萨拉森人，温德人叛乱了。你有所有这些好斗的贵族。王位上有一个三岁的男孩，到处都是拾荒者，看起来是一场灾难。但塞奥法诺稳住了局面，而且不仅仅是稳住了局面。她让萨克森再次伟大。你知道，她稳定了边境。她与瑞典人、丹麦人、基辅的弗拉基米尔大帝修补了条约。
Yeah. And Dominic with Basil the Second. Basil the Bulgar Slayer. Yes. Great character. And I have to say, I was always team Basil the Second. Were you? I wasn't on the side of the Bulgarians.
是的，多米尼克，还有巴西尔二世。保加利亚屠夫巴西尔。是的。伟大的角色。我必须说，我一直是巴西尔二世的支持者。你是吗？我不是站在保加利亚人那边的。
But now my personal trainer, S trainer simeon is a bulgarian but i'll just give him a shout out ejects brixton if anyone wants the best personal trainer you will ever find he is your man well he won't like this basil the bulgar slayer he was a ruthless man wasn't he he captured 15 000 prisoners blinded 99 out of every 100 and got the 100th to lead them back to Bulgaria. And the Bulgarian Tsar, Samuel, was so shocked. He dropped down out of a stroke. Yeah, I know. So I've talked about this with Simeon. What's he say? He doesn't approve of it at all as behaviour. You will know, Tom, that I'm a great Bulgarophile, actually. I've been to Bulgaria twice. I've become a massive Bulgarophile now. It's a great country. Anyway, this is all by the by. So this is all part of
但现在我的私人教练西蒙是保加利亚人，但我会向他致敬，如果有人想要你所能找到的最好的私人教练，他就是你要找的人。好吧，他不会喜欢这个保加利亚屠夫巴西尔的，他是个冷酷的人，不是吗？他俘虏了15000名囚犯，弄瞎了每100人中的99人，并让第100个人带他们回保加利亚。保加利亚沙皇萨穆伊尔太震惊了。他中风倒下了。是的，我知道。所以我已经和西蒙谈过这个了。他怎么说？他根本不赞成这种行为。你会知道，汤姆，我实际上是一个伟大的保加利亚迷。我去过保加利亚两次。我现在已经成为一个巨大的保加利亚迷了。这是一个伟大的国家。总之，这都是题外话。所以这一切都是
Theophanu's approach. She's kind of making international friends, stabilising the frontiers. Yeah. Presiding as a simulacrum of the Virgin Mary, radiant in jewels and silks.
塞奥法诺方法的一部分。她正在结交国际朋友，稳定边境。是的。作为圣母玛利亚的化身，在珠宝和丝绸中闪耀。
And I think through sheer force of personality, keeps a kingdom that her son can then inherit. Yeah. She actually dies in 991, so relatively young. And Adelaide, so Otto III's grandmother, Theophanu's mother-in-law, the wife of Otto the Great, she comes in and takes over. But Theophanu, she is given rave reviews. So a
我认为通过纯粹的人格力量，她保留了一个她的儿子随后可以继承的王国。是的。她实际上在991年去世，所以相对年轻。阿德莱德，也就是奥托三世的祖母，塞奥法诺的婆婆，大帝奥托的妻子，她进来接管了。但塞奥法诺，她得到了极高的评价。所以一位
chronicler called Thietmar, who was the Prince Bishop of Merseburg, quite fancy being a Prince Bishop. He wrote of Theophany, though of the weaker sex, she was moderate in all her actions, trustworthy and possessed of perfect manners. So again, this emphasis on her table manners. These qualities enabled her to preserve for her son, his royal authority and to do so with a masculine degree of vigilance. She was friends to all who did honestly by her, but devastating to foes and rebels. She sounds great, Tom. That's again, a bit like St. Olga. Yeah, I think she is great. And I think the biggest tribute to her impact is the character of her son, Otto III, who will rule
名叫蒂特马尔的编年史家，他是梅泽堡的亲王主教，我很想成为亲王主教。他写道，关于塞奥法诺，虽然属于弱势性别，但她在所有行动中都很温和，值得信赖，并拥有完美的礼仪。所以再次强调了她的餐桌礼仪。这些品质使她能够为她的儿子保留他的王权，并以一种男性化的警惕性来做到这一点。她是所有诚实对待她的人的朋友，但对敌人和叛乱分子来说是毁灭性的。她听起来很棒，汤姆。这又有点像圣奥尔加。是的，我认为她很棒。我认为对她影响力的最大致敬是她儿子奥托三世的性格，他将在千禧年，即1000年统治
as emperor in the millennial year, the year 1000. And he's one of the most remarkable rulers, not just in the Middle Ages, but in the whole of European history, really extraordinary figure who fuses the Saxon and the Byzantine, and who is convinced that it is his destiny to unite both halves of the Roman Empire and to rule as this mythic figure, the last Roman emperor, because there are these traditions that are very, very current in Constantinople and with which Theophanu would undoubtedly have been incredibly familiar, that at the end of days, both halves of the empire will be united. The last Roman emperor will defeat all his enemies. He will then go on pilgrimage to Jerusalem. He will climb the hill
作为皇帝。他是中世纪乃至整个欧洲历史上最杰出的统治者之一，确实是一个非凡的人物，他融合了萨克森和拜占庭，并且坚信他的命运是统一罗马帝国的两个部分，并作为这个神话人物，最后的罗马皇帝进行统治，因为在君士坦丁堡有这些非常、非常流行的传统，塞奥法诺无疑对此非常熟悉，即在末日，帝国的两个部分将统一。最后的罗马皇帝将击败他所有的敌人。然后他将去耶路撒冷朝圣。他将爬上
of Golgotha. He will take off his crown. A cross will descend. And at the same time, Antichrist will appear enthroned on the site of the temple. Yeah. And I think we should do an episode on Arthur III later. It's a brilliant, brilliant story. I think this conviction comes from Theophanu. And so that is why I think she can justifiably be called the Empress of the
各各他山。他将摘下他的皇冠。一个十字架将降临。与此同时，敌基督将出现在圣殿遗址上加冕。是的。我认为我们以后应该做一期关于奥托三世的节目。这是一个非常、非常精彩的故事。我认为这种信念来自塞奥法诺。所以这就是为什么我认为她可以被正当地称为末日女皇。
Apocalypse. Because she thinks the apocalypse is coming and she prepares her son for it. I think she probably does. I mean, what's interesting is that the Byzantines are much less saturated in the imagery of the book of Revelation, which talks of the thousand year reign. So I think the year 1000 has much less significance for them. But in this period, when she's growing up, there is an absolute obsession in Constantinople with the figure of the last Roman emperor and also anxieties and hopes that the end of the world is approaching. So there's this kind of great swirl of prophecies, of hopes, of fears. And I think that Theophanu obviously takes those with her to Saxony and imbues Otto III with them. Right. A lot of that apocalyptic paranoia,
因为她认为末日即将来临，她为她的儿子做好了准备。我想她可能确实是这样。我的意思是，有趣的是，拜占庭人对《启示录》中谈论千年统治的意象的沉浸程度要低得多。所以我认为1000年对他们来说意义要小得多。但在她成长的这个时期，君士坦丁堡对最后一位罗马皇帝的形象有着绝对的痴迷，同时也存在着世界末日即将来临的焦虑和希望。所以有这种巨大的预言、希望、恐惧的漩涡。我认为塞奥法诺显然把这些带到了萨克森，并以此熏陶了奥托三世。对。很多那种末日偏执，
almost, or expectation that you see at the turn of the millennium, you think to some degree she fuels that. It is debated. It is a very live debate how many apocalyptic anxieties there are in Latin Europe in the year 1000. I think there are a lot. And I would, I mean, hopefully at some point, maybe next year, make the case for that and look at Otto III and look at those kind of apocalyptic anxieties. But I think Theophanou, her story is fascinating in its own right, but also as a kind of foreshadowing of what is to come.
几乎，或者你在千年之交看到的期望，你认为在某种程度上她助长了这一点。这有争议。关于1000年的拉丁欧洲有多少末日焦虑是一个非常活跃的辩论。我认为有很多。我的意思是，希望在某个时候，也许明年，能为此辩护，看看奥托三世，看看那种末日焦虑。但我认为塞奥法诺，她的故事本身就很迷人，而且也是一种对未来的预示。
All right. Brilliant, Tom. Very exciting. A really, really fascinating story. A nice light shone on an otherwise murky corner of medieval history. So on that bombshell, Tom, thank you so much for that. A tour de force. And we will see you next time.
好的。太棒了，汤姆。非常令人兴奋。一个非常、非常迷人的故事。为中世纪历史上一个原本阴暗的角落照亮了一盏灯。所以在这个重磅炸弹上，汤姆，非常感谢你。杰作。我们下次再见。
Goodbye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。